welcome to this video playing bagel hats
FMB go ahead it was wrong retards and I
see snow but only cuz ya both notorious
time players ok ok so let's see what the
bigger head is doing check
yeah this line Kansas a mission really
had a very bad reputation for a long
time and then you run was contemplated
the world championships played with see
for him I think it was c4 in this
position almost no not not really not
really i'm sorry I'm wishy of course has
had f3 later really early on k let's go
here hey I should have taken him I'm not
I'm really am always unsure if I should
take or let on Oh interesting or letter
Y to take submit surprising how is he
preventing you for now with h5 maybe
this is this kind of idea
we're getting before it really looks
awful okay take stakes 94 yes yeah he's
playing one new tricks of course just
give me just one second look Bishop b2
lutely 1.e4 and blacks position is bad
yeah one move tricks
Nexus 6 is really in there anyway the
Knights misplaced on c6 very clearly it
just plays on a one mover and a stumble
it to it and of course I immediately see
it after I play you for okay and this is
the kind of interesting so III looks
like and maybe you can actually take
takes look chicks still 94 okay i'm
still not deform so stuff like night h5
you still can take one define
and then let's get get out of this if
you take on g2 might have Luke f6 for
some wacky complications
it's not that easy to play at least for
black
it's not easy to play it takes on g2
that it's really dangerous even Queen g2
a simple Queen g2 weather okay then then
25 is probably good so he's just saying
that night at five is not any good or
not a 5k and Queenie six long row
yeah so probably should have just played
Rugare 3 and waited with a 5k so i can
actually take on the six it's not
completely completely clear that this is
any good I'll take it to actually I can
take h2 for some wacky desperado
whatever too weird game I thought it
would but this consider to take on g2
but guess not
chihiro give 95 we have 78 probably
chattel thing like this kind of is
probably interesting 95 rook f5 maybe
look f5 f6 now what is the that's made
on f7 huh what is he doing now have
seven meet eyes it's the king of little
tricks here the Sky King check check
that's the very unclear see one is
dangerous hmm that's where I should
shift on yet really should have done
that seep one is really dangerous shoot
19 26 time morning Wow
no that is upon us probably just winning
here who create was also very stupid on
the weird game check yeah yeah i sees
those one this one's for you wanna check
for c3m
check
check check check check white chair
resides oh it's sorry for the game that
the Milan just playing to understand
making very stupid mistakes and and also
i don't know i don't know and see that
also very quickly or whether back here
in 96 so if Roy yeah I'm and I'm
immediately see that this is based on
this this is one mover with 94 otherwise
the night is just misplaced there on
that square pretty clearing I should
just go here rookie 1.e4 and this leads
to a fantastic attack simply because
that would set up it's not any good it
really isn't ya like like here went ok I
can think about this if I want to give
away a three or not and I think I can
probably do this okay it can sacrifice
on d4 again for some points so maybe
okay the engine wants to do this prep
move and only now go here for it just
gives white a slight advantage which is
conservative Queen g6 here so probably a
little bit more some more prep moves and
it's just a very dangerous attack and
now things get very weird and now maybe
just drew gave three I didn't see that
rookie to shot of course maybe just
something like this
kill the computer likes likes black with
instant looks very dangerous g6 like
it's bad I according to them just
defending ya head she found this is
short Stan into someone here yeah no
check yeah that's okay for like I mean
it's really okay Jim Troy this is all
probably just a mistake i have to go
rook e8 or something i have to prevent
channel 96 really and this is this is a
big problem maybe this one I get to see
porn I can maybe save the game jack I
mean not more on this is the the engine
line check
but probably going to be a draw check
yeah yeah I'm losing in many ways just
it's just terrible just a terrible
position what if we get game who deviate
game yeah it's always this kind of you
you make them but you immediately see
that it I mean I just registered 96mm
weird move yeah I think well 97th it's
just far more normal yeah I guess anyway
and lucky for all right and then I
merely see that this is 94 tactic and
then here while he played that well all
those I mean 26 probably is right
probably is right and whether the
computer actually deserves Wow hey want
to do this and gives this is equal yeah
okay i'm somewhat active but
talk to hard to tell exactly why this
should be equal anyway tough game thanks
for watching